[Applause]
deme Burnett has found her happy ending
the bachelor in paradise star walked
away from her time on the show with a
fiance Christian Haggerty we just met
but it wasn't an easy journey for Demi
the franchise's first openly bisexual
contestant here's what she had to say
about the experience of coming out on TV
to Ellen DeGeneres it was a lot of fear
it was fear of judgment it was fear of
disappointing people in my life making
them uncomfortable right it was just
really hard it was really scary yet I
mean it all worked but ultimately yes
yeah I'll say not only did Ellen praised
Emmy for her bravery but she gifted the
couple with a honeymoon in Bali Demi is
feeling pretty good about her
relationship and she isn't afraid to
dish the dirt on her co-stars
in fact when Ellen asked which couple
she's most concerned for following the
finale she said Chris and Katie I know
that Katie is an optimist and she sees
the good she gets glimpses of the good
parts of Chris but I think that Chris
needs to step it up like if he wants to
keep her right and I think that she
needs to you know tell him to step it up
yeah and I know that she is but you know
honestly it's like couples counseling
it's not a negative thing just a quick
refresher Chris and Katie got engaged
during the finale of the show after a
season of ups and downs
[Music]
et caught up with Demi following her own
engagement where she shared her hopes
for the future of LGBTQ couples in
bachelor nation I don't want to be the
one to carry the torch of how bachelor
nation or bachelor franchise should like
react to all of this kind of stuff I
think that it just will happen naturally
hopefully everything will just be
normalized you know it won't be like oh
the queer couple would be like oh the
couple as for whether she'd get married
on the reality show
well she had this to say if it's pretty
sure yes girl works the reality Fame for
a free wedding because that stuff is
expensive the 24 year old also told ET
that she and Christian don't have a
timeline for when they'd like to tie the
knot it's like bachelor prom is faster
than the engagement that's what I'm
gonna be like actually like take the
time that be slow about it yeah you're
like wait a minute okay let's be normal
for a bit and date and have fun and then
the wedding will come and while the
couple may not be in a rush to head down
the aisle they know their love is the
real deal it's insane how we're so
different but it just works so well you
know I'm so blunt and bold and all kinds
of things and she's so gentle and
understanding and so sweet and soft and
it's just like a perfect balance oh I
love love and I love these two together
of course
et will be right here to bring you all
the latest bachelor bachelorette
bachelor in paradise news so make sure
to keep it locked or right here until
next time I'm Holly Stephens bye for now
[Music]
you